hi everybody it's kevin van aarde I'm
seating here seating I'm seating here
I'm seated here with Josh sha sha sha or
hate hello I'm good I'm actually great
couple of space programs out and it's I
think the best game I've ever played so
really yeah that's that now that see
that's high praise it's not a fair
comparison because it's different than
other games but I've never had as much
fun or spent as much time in one game
all right you know how much time I've
spent with kerbal space program zero ok
well let's so I want to see what this
thing is I actually already know what
this thing is but why don't you show
everybody else what this thing is all
right so when you start if you were new
to this game I'd recommend doing like a
science career but we're just going to
do the sandbox cousin like there's a lot
of parts and this game is really
complicated but like the science one
lets you kind of do it like bit by bit
and learn what each of the parts do kind
of more so it's more like an extent it's
like your introductory yeah campaign in
a way exactly and then there is like a
career mode but that has like funds and
it has like reputation and so you don't
really want to like dig into it too fast
or you'll regret it right so like
science doesn't really penalize you for
failing as much so our goal today is to
get to the moon so on moon mu n yeah
it's all good it's all very cute Kevin
is it really well right now it just
looks very scientific but I do see when
I look down below those are like normal
people yeah they're all doing their
signs like there's always like different
characters in this world name like gene
kerman and stuff after like Gene Kranz
and then there's like Werner von karman
they're all like joke names based on
actual guys in space history so anyways
this is our command pod it's just a
one-seater will kind of do a smaller
rocket and idea is to land on the moon
and then make it back alive so yeah
there's a lot of parts and it's kind of
complicated but so is there a is there a
process for upgrading these things or do
i do i just have access to everything I
need from the very beginning how does
that do that's what sandbox is so this
if you just started playing the game
this would be extremely
overwhelming right but if you're doing
sand like science then you'll unlock the
small engines first and bigger and
bigger parts and then you can they're
only be like three things here and then
you can kind of figure out what they all
do so what is it that's keeping you like
if your goal is just to get to the moon
and come back mm-hmm then what's keeping
you from just doing basically the same
set up every time like once you know
something that works what's what's
making you want to do it in another way
well if you wanted to get to the moon
over and over that wouldn't be
considered like too much of a challenge
because you can also go to other planets
and like leaving the local planet and
going to another one's gonna require
like a much bigger ship in much more
planning than just a simple trip to the
moon so you kind of expand on it that
way but we don't need I mean that can
take a long time and like if you fail it
at any one step you might have to start
over you there are like kind of cheats
to like quick save or a little bit so
how far out into the I mean am i
confined to a solar system how far out
into the solar system am I going to be
able to get there is just one solar
system which I will be able to show you
take your time i'm just watching you so
this is modular is it you know to what
effect does it matter where you put
certain elements like I see right now
you're just dragging and dropping things
on is it important where those things
are going at this stage to some extent
and it's gotten more important with the
new update it just hit one point oh it's
been in early access for a long time I
was playing it pretty heavily a year ago
but so there it is physics-based like
these are RCS thrusters which will use
to land this thing on the moon and like
if they're around the center of mass
which is right there then it'll be able
to control it better so that buttons
just showing you where the center of
mass is currently on the and there's a
center of thrust I'm going to stuff like
that you can also build airplanes so the
center of lift there is useful so yeah I
mean I don't want to go into each little
detail because there's just so much but
but these are all different parts is is
there does everything serve a purpose is
there is there a point where things you
can cosmetically change the way things
look yeah and like there's a few ways to
do
some things like but at the end of the
day a lot of it's really just stuff is
getting bigger and bigger like there's
little parts and then there's big parts
and then there's like tiny parts like
you can build miniaturize things not
everything has to be manned so you can
do probes and stuff right all right so
this will be our Lander here and then
we're going to need something to get it
to the moon and off the planet so I had
some more rockets what helped rockets
it's so I'm looking forward to seeing
where the physics come in obviously
right now it's hovering in midair so
physics haven't really come in yet but I
you know as a as a physics dilettante
myself I'm a rather intrigued to see
where this goes especially because in
the entertainment that we often know and
love space and physics are not
represented in any kind of authentic
manner right so I wouldn't say the
simulations like extremely realistic
here but it's it's definitely a lot
closer than you'll get in most movies
like interstellar did some pretty cool
stuff and like a lot of it was really
accurate but there's still some things
or it's like I don't know if that would
really work that way like there's
actually a ton of stuff an interstellar
that's messed up to but they did dry
better than most one of the things that
still bothers me as an inhabitable
planet orbiting a black hole which which
seems to be incredibly unlikely but
anyway moving on yes the gamespot
interstellar stream yeah I mean but like
I love Star Wars but now it's like kind
of hard to watch a little after playing
this game like you'll just like know
things like a ship's not going to fly
towards a planet if it's trying to land
on it it'll be like firing its Rockets
away from it to slow down because it's
in orbit of it so right that sort of
stuff no longer makes any sense so yeah
this will kind of be our ship hopefully
it's enough to see
one tip if you're new to this game is
these struts you just put them
everywhere for extra strength you what
are the limits that you've got on
something like that like can you only
make this so heavy can you you know is
there a mass limit is there you know
like a number of objects limit there is
in career that you can upgrade the
buildings as you go so you can get a
bigger hangar bay like this and you can
get a bigger launch pad in sandbox it's
kind of only constrained by your PC's
capabilities right and like people
there's a really great like community
for a kerbal space program even when I'm
not like playing it regularly I'll check
it out on Reddit and stuff other like
weird stuff people are building but um
people will build like giant stuff and
they'll have to record it it like a
couple friends a second I mean is it
also possible to you know to just mess
up in terms of how you create your craft
like something is it possible to get
something out into space and into orbit
and then realize that you messed up in
there and and it's just it's bound to
crash because you didn't handle all the
time I jump earlier cuz what earlier and
that exact same thing happened and then
like I was messing with the new update
and like instantly killed my character
and I had it on kind of like he doesn't
come back mode and I can't revert it so
I killed jebadiah's like the hero of
this game good job and then I started in
order and I was like no I can handle it
so Bob Jones is asking a few questions
that I think I already know the answer
to before even get to them the first is
how that you know do the ship's get
faster than light travel and of course
the answer is going to be no the answer
is going to be no of course because it's
based in like kind of as much real that
wait what's this Q soon as much realism
as they can kind of hope to achieve is
there a fast forward though I mean you
get to the point where I mean we send
things into into space all the time and
it takes months and months and months
and years and years I mean one of the
voyagers is only now just sort of on you
know on the edge of the solar system
sometimes possibly in interstellar space
nobody's ever quite sure but so there is
a like a fast forward like if you're
sending
something that far out there is a fast
forward it's definitely in this game
like they said they wanted to do
multiplayer as a later update and I'm
not sure how that work because fast
forward is such a crucial part to
playing it like I don't know how there
can be any sort of consistent like time
or anything are there any other any
other species out there in space no no
that that would be kind of cool so they
really are going sort of for an
authentic vibe where that's concerned
except of course the little people are
those things are those called kerbals
one of the day are called kerbals and so
let's check out my crew so I'm
definitely going to rock jebediah kerman
1 point 0 added girl curb kerbals for
the first time so yeah that's about damn
time I know what took so I would say
yeah what's up with that and it's cool
like I started playing this several
updates ago and now there's like
different types of scientists with
different skills like pilots engineers
there's just a lot of like little
details that you can like care about a
lot or just kind of choose to ignore my
staging is almost up somebody warp kid
is asking about I think it's hard to say
how to answer how realistic fuel
consumption management are because I
don't think we're actually rocket
scientists but at least I'm not Josh are
you a rocket scientist I feel like one
sometimes but no not okay so how does
that act like fuel management
consumption I can tell you real quick
but let me just say that anything you
want to be harder or more realistic
there's a mod for and it's almost
impossible to play this game without
modding it a little like this down here
is from a mod that shows me these stats
and like you just have to be it's really
easy to mod you just basically download
it and drop it in the game data folder
right the company's really supportive of
it and they want you to mod it so but
for now what I have is these for fuel
rockets on the outside and then this
yellow duct is going to pump it's
pulling fuel from no it's this engines
pulling fuel from the outside and you'll
see what happens later is once I kind of
run out a few on the outside and drop
these tanks the middle one will still
have full fuel which is pretty good so
we're gonna actually try a liftoff then
saying let Kevin play out oh I don't
think you want me to play that's
somebody in the game spot
so I it took me a while to open
everything up and now I've got twitch
chat and GameSpot chat open so make sure
to to ask me any questions that you want
yeah I mean somebody mentioned
translating this game to live stream it
is pretty hard because a lot of this
game is is spent putting stuff together
and testing stuff out and failing and
doing it again yeah that's the big part
is the failing and doing it again that's
what this might be a one-way trip left
to see I don't know if I have enough
fuel to get home I didn't really think
about it that much I just kind of threw
it all together and I was recently
playing this game again but I really
played it more heavily a year ago and a
lots changed since then what has changed
i mean when you've been playing since
early access what is the what is the
course of the game been like as somebody
who's been there from the beginning a
huge one that was with this update is
more realistic area dynamic so like a
lot of those crazy pictures you'd see an
old kerbal space program they like
aren't really possible anymore because
your ship would fall apart or something
and like now I'm kind of going over the
speed of sound and like you can see the
wind on that craft like it used to be
really hard to break the sound barrier
with the rocket but now it's pretty
simple which means you have to kind of
like adjust the way you fly and do a
more casual turn throughout the entire
thing nature's far in the game spot chat
it's interesting he's saying you know
he's wondering if you're using any any
mods what so are you and what's the mod
community for this game I'm using one
mod called kerbal engineer and then i'm
also using a little hot fix patch
someone made that like kind of fixes the
way heat shields work and that's it in
this pack I've done a lot of mods in the
past where you had like a bunch of parts
from NASA and stuff but the community is
really great it's through the curse page
now so this thing's bending I mean you I
you know could you have you made
something that's been too long it's just
broken yeah that's another kind of
problem you can have and like I have the
auto stabilizer turned on if you turn
that off usually it's a bit more stable
this might be just getting a guy on the
moon and not getting them home some
people don't think you're going to make
it they probably know how to play this
game better than me and they're like not
enough Delta V all right we'll get this
up to a hundred kilometers and then it's
worth pointing out to that this is a
this is a not earth this is this is a
fictional solar system so it looks like
Earth but it's not earth yeah it's code
and there's really nothing on the planet
except your launch center which is kind
of lame I mean it makes sense this game
isn't they don't need to build a whole
planet full of stuff but when you like
flat playing around there's really not a
lot to see right but as far as I class
and stuff is concerned like this planet
and the moon or is like I think a fifth
the size of ours which means it's a lot
easier to get off of it right and they
have a mod called the real real solar
system and that's like kind of what the
hard play hard core players will do for
a big challenge all right we'll see I'm
gonna get closer in the upper left all
those arrows is the own kind of time
warp and stuff yeah just sees people
seem that you'll probably get to the
moon they're a little worried about
getting back I ya know I'm worried about
landing on the moon too so it might not
even be an issue okay but is that a big
part especially at first like is it you
know it is and as they're fun and
failure like is it fun to actually try
stuff out and see how badly it goes
actually I made sure it's the fun with
that it is like a lot of the fun in this
game and also if you can manage to like
just barely survive and get your guys
stranded somewhere like a lot of the fun
in this game really comes from like the
rescue missions and stuff to les Moonves
the CEO of CBS Hylas mls he wants to
know wit engines you're using on the
upper stages on the upper stages i'm
using the terrier here and the
it's just a really small normal one I
like on the bottom one to use a swivel
one because it's gimballed so you can
move it around and then i'll let the
outside ones I use the like similar one
that's not good and so you can set these
maneuver mote nodes and I'm just kind of
matching that burn and it'll circularize
okay I ran out of fuel so spacebar to
stage and go to the next stage all right
that's about good enough and now our
goal is going to be either moon maybe I
should go to amend this there's a second
one on this planet and it's further away
but it's easier to land on because of
gravity soil but it's our I said the
moon of a good of them have you have you
noticed any any differences like I'm
curious just how deep the physics
simulation goes I mean it so far it
looks Newtonian and but I'm kind of
wondering how even even within Newtonian
physics like how deep is that going to
go in terms of like are you have to be
really careful like let's say you know
do you have things like Lagrange points
that you need to think about stuff like
that guys so yeah there aren't Lagrange
points because that would require
simulating like multiple kind of the
pull of multiple planets at the same
time and there's really only a single
one at a time so like
it would be called angin like
simulations if they simulated like you
know what's Jupiter doing to our moods
right now and everything right this is
the full solar system but they aren't
really doing that and so there's
actually a lot of advantages to not
doing that besides processing and one of
them is like if you have a bunch of
satellites you don't really want to like
keep going back to them to do
station-keeping like it is a game it's
not that realistic oh you know what I
totally forgot power I don't have any
solar panels what were you thinking
that's gonna come into play later is
there a couple of people and the twitch
chat asking some interesting questions
like you know could you launch a space
station that the orbits the planet and
then you could launch shuttles from it
absolutely and like that's one cool
thing about this game there's a lot of
stuff you can do and one thing that's
not cool about this game is not a lot of
it is like really that helpful unless
you're kind of just like role-playing
like once you get a space station into
orbit like as cool as you make it like
it's not that useful could I only have
one craft in in play at a time I don't
know you can have as many z1 so if I
want to build a whole fleet of things I
can build a whole fleet send them up
there and pretend that they're you know
like if I want I could build a space
station and then send shuttles out there
too you have to maintain it or whatever
and then bring them back and try to make
a whole system out of that if I wanted
to mm-hmm and one thing I haven't really
am messed with yet in this game is no
not target I can do Inuvik one thing
that they've added with this update is
resource gathering and I haven't really
had time to mess with it but the idea
there is you can maybe make a space
station around the moon and gather
resources and convert it to fuel and
then you could like kind of take your
inner interplanetary ship their fuel up
and then head out somewhere else without
kind of wasting all that fuel getting
out of right the gravity will hear
somebody mentioning and sounds alphason
mentioning that one thing that he did is
like he'd never even made it into orbit
so he just made a mini game out of
landing on different the different
masses on the planet just to see if he
could do that so it sounds like they're
actually quite a lot of ways to make
your own fun did you just go inside the
craft like how deep does this does the
cockpit simulation I mean it's this but
the dials generally work like here's
your I don't know why it's so dark I can
try and pull it and see if I can get
some light in here some of them like
this is the really early cockpit but
some of the ones later have really cool
interiors and like you can see the other
guy in there with you right oh yeah I
mean some people really get into the
airplane building part of this and like
you don't even really have to leave the
planet for that of course error a bunch
of numbers is indicating that if you do
want to do that station round like build
stuff out there and and kind of simulate
that kind of thing that mods are the way
to go there are a lot of mods out there
specifically for that kind of play yeah
they have like really cool like um even
stuff like how you it might require you
to have food and stuff on in life
support stuff on the station just to add
like that touch of realism apparently
they generate science now yeah so that's
the science career oh yeah so I think
they did change that so over time if you
have like the science module up you'll
get more science which is cool so I like
those changes i really wish like there's
more of a point for a lot of that stuff
all right I might have getting a little
messy is there anything you beyond that
is there anything you feel this game
should be doing that it's not doing I
mean I still do think it has problems
like teaching a lot of people how to
play it well and then there's like
little stuff like a I don't know that
was a big one like what's the point of a
unmanned ship when you get more science
when you have like a guy they're doing a
coup report thing and then like to get
to another planet I feel like you need
you can't learn how to do that in the
game you need to have like a YouTube
video and or a mod to show you how to
get to like another planet I really
don't think anyone can just mess with
this guy
a long time and figure out how to get
away from the earth right and that's
kind of that's weird to me so that sort
of thing it's always been a struggle
with them and maybe they'll be able to
spend more time on that now because the
games out there still going to keep like
developing it in everything so we'll see
all right and again people mentioning
that when it comes to streams this is a
tough one because there's a lot of
what's taking place its first of all
it's a slower pace so you're talking
about you know pulling this off over a
longer period of time and there's
there's also the fact that a lot of this
is taking place in your mind you know
you're making mental adjustments here
you're making decisions but in terms of
screen activity yeah it's something I'm
sure one thing that's like kind of going
off in my mind is that solar panel thing
that's again right now josh is really
worried about power and I don't blame
you because okay but you do have a nice
little whipping around thing going on
here it looks like you're going to whip
past now I'm behind them and if I don't
do anything i'm going to whip past so
what you need to do is burn get in it
orbit here but it does it does simulate
that so you at least you're able to see
what the where the trajectory is going
to take you right you don't have to like
make guesses yeah unless you want to I
suppose you could turn that stuff off
right oh yeah and once you get used to
it the moon isn't really um too tough
let's see you in orbit now oh yeah I
guess I could have done a cool approach
and that would win a good idea
alright we're just going to go for this
I've got a lot of fuel left here which
is kind of a shame I'm just gonna go
straight into the ground so you're just
gonna maybe it would be good to do in
orbit and come around and land on the
daylight side though do that okay that's
like I know that's a good idea Kevin
well to be fair was your idea I just
agreed all right sorry we could suddenly
got very very quiet because four is um
on interesting as it might look on
screen this starts to get pretty tense
when you're even even I'm starting to
like feel tense on Josh's behalf as I
sit here hoping yeah the good thing is I
failed so many times that hopefully
don't cry it's kind of like Dark Souls
in that way though you know what I mean
we're like if you're scared of dying
you're not gonna get very far in that
game okay so i only have lander legs
appear so even though i have some fuel
here i'm gonna have to ditch this before
too long because of bad planning people
or people are lamenting your lack of
reaction wheels I don't know what's that
I don't need him he doesn't need them
doing all our CS how much did that did
some I turn that thing off
oh [ __ ] I do like this is one feature it
kind of like the pilots are now kind of
able to steer a little bit and there's
something I Slyke conveniences that are
running out of electricity okay the
graphics mods for this I know this seems
like a really shallow question no it's
not in there are and there's some really
really cool ones like there's something
to Adam like a lot of effects and then
there's texture packs for all the
planets and everything like the modding
community besides like Skyrim it's the
most like advanced I've seen and like
every time a new update comes out like
everyone's updating them instantly it
seems like there's much a really cool
stuff I'm trying to keep it like pretty
simple with this display here but I
really like the NASA ones in the Soviet
wants to kind of have that like realism
alpha sim thinks you should try to land
at a crater you think you've got that in
you will see I don't have too much
ability to change where I land looks
like I'm gonna end just past that crater
by half a mile okay Oh crashing let's do
somebody's somebody's bringing up by
time dilation but I don't I don't this
scale we're not going to be worried
about any time dilation knows there's
nothing no time dilation worth noting
Ian you're staying in the solar stuff
not going very fast I don't I don't
think there's anything really
relativistic about any of this stuff i
don't i don't think i mean and
ultimately it's not asking you to
consider pretty little hunter some don't
know any of that concept Oh Josh I'm
worried for you
oh no it's over oh you know they're
gonna go on quick saved oh yeah oops
yeah there's no quick save or I didn't
do any saves all right well that came up
pretty bad we can see if we can see this
all that remains is my parachute all
right cool um we can go back to the
Space Center you killed your pilot I
know that was pretty very upsetting all
dead what's his name again i forgot that
was jebadiah oh je-- boudia r.i.p
jebediah IP alright so we can do a quick
like career flight i'll get my career on
here and then you can kind of see what
the tech tree looks like which i think
is a really kind of fun way to play the
game so these are my like an upgraded
will bring it to daytime see these
buildings are smaller the roads are all
still here but it's not really it's
interesting yeah so here's my tech tree
so far so you need science which you
spend to unlock each of these nodes and
then you get bigger and bigger rockets
and then like there's nuclear rockets
which have like a really great
efficiency in space so you can those are
really good frame her planetary and then
there's all the resource gathering which
is a pretty cool addition so I was also
trying in this career to UM get a probe
on the moon and then I crashed it
yesterday I'm not doing good with my
landings somebody suggested somebody
says you should have stayed and gone and
recovered the parachute you're like a
rescue mission know that whatever here
and and that's that's the thing like
it's I I think you know I I understood
the appeal of this when people described
it's me again I've never played it
myself but I think I'm now really
starting to even understand more of the
appeal in terms of the role-playing
appeal which is that oh and here you go
you've got you know you've got your sort
of your your career challenges here
yeah some of these are a little weird
but they added tourists and this one
which is kind of funny where these guys
all want to go they want to fly by the
moon and then land and then you'll get
some money for that I did kind of cheat
you can kind of make your own difficulty
and so I said it so that like reputation
doesn't really matter because i don't
know i don't really like thinking about
that one but on like there's still a
budget so if i fail too many times and i
run out of money then i'll kind of be in
trouble and then so i think there's some
people stranded in orbit that i have to
rescue as like one of the UM mission
goals i have oh I have to put satellites
in these orbits here so that's not like
extremely interesting but there's a guy
sticker on the moon i can try and grab
or this guy Oh after Sam um alright
salmon let's get Sam room back so I have
these like ambulance chips which are
kind of funny it's like one of those old
kerbal things where it's like you just
like make it work however you want
before I had this pod thing I had like a
bunch of these stacked on top of each
other which doesn't look right well
whatever gets you off the ground in the
early hours right mmm
okay thank ambulance one of these is
better or they're all the same one or
the other
okay we'll just do this so these are
these are ships that you you've created
on the past you can you gain access to
them after you save them mmhmm yeah you
can just save all your different types
of ships like a lot of times once you
get later on in the game you might end
up having like a certain ship to get you
to or like you'll build the lower part
of ships at different sizes and then you
can kind of save them as a sub assembly
and then use like the same lifter for
each kind of thing and then you'll just
change the all the details at the top
what are some of the more drastic
failures you've had like what are some
of the things that that you can't
believe you did that there's all sort
like one of the most common ones in this
game has to be like having your
parachute go off at the same time your
engines go off so like it's pulling you
down and you like flip around and stuff
and it's all about like which order
everything happens when you hit spacebar
so like paying attention to that's
pretty critical and then yeah and
another thing like i was trying i was
finally trying to use like airplanes and
i ended up crashing like killing two
guys like in a row just trying to learn
how to fly or learn how to land I don't
know this game can be unforgiving but so
I'm told included in twitch by AA bhi
hai ji OC that this is a game for people
with beards glasses and no sex life so I
assume that he means me but I'd like to
mention that my sex life is absolutely
one healthy yeah thank you very much I
had to have otherwise yes maybe this is
a game for somebody with beard glasses
and a very healthy sex life I got pretty
addicted to a year ago and I mean my
girlfriend had to have like the Kerbal
talk I had to like kind of play it less
for time it only lasted for a couple
weeks but I was really really into it I
mean a game that that takes place over a
scale like this I mean ultimately you're
going to be spending more time with it
by very nature right because it takes
longer
or things to happen and you get involved
in that moment to moment sort of
manipulation right yeah and I mean you
kind of think you'll log on and do one
thing but when you kind of have your own
career and you like keep putting more
and more satellites up in orbit and like
trying to get one more trip to do nun or
something which is Mars you can easily
blow like an entire day playing this
game and I've done it still regret it no
not at all there you go I always
recommend this to people and I think
that they're intimidated to play it but
I feel like anyone should like get
someone on the moon and see how you feel
and then like if you want to quit
they're fine but you should at least try
and take it that far talk sweet thinks
maybe add some clear bowl for play I'll
just let let everybody figured that one
out for themselves
yeah so the idea is this guy's really
far out there he's like past the moon
but we're going to try and rendezvous
with them and actually rendevouz are
they're complicated but they're probably
not that interesting to see happen I'm
curious to watch you pull that off
especially especially because we saw a
crash so now I'm really rooting for you
to pull off the mission oh you know that
I forgot to bring am that engineer mod
so I'll have to do this a little more
manual a 20 oops it should be all right
that's kind of more of a convenience
thing for things like this but
forgetting to another planet you really
need something like that another one
that's good for beginners is called mech
Jeb and it kind of has some like
autopilot functions and stuff like it
can be useful to see that do something
and then you can try it on your own
later definitely check out mods and
check out like the subreddit the
community there is pretty cool like
anytime someone like crash lands their
first time on I mean everyone will be
like Oh excited you see I feel all
shallow but one of the first things I
would want probably is to is to just I
mean what's great is the game Ozzie
obviously is meant to play on a variety
of computers it's not too intensive I
mean when you look at the textures close
up there they're not terribly advanced
and whatnot mm-hmm but I would really
love to see this with a more you know
with something buffed up with like lots
of lots of detail applied to glens moons
and like one that makes a huge
difference is there's different types of
cloud mods and blow nice that'll really
change it I like how they sort of make
that look kind of like Africa and Europe
mm-hmm but not really yeah it's kind of
like someone just went crazy in
Photoshop with like copying pasting
earth and for some reason it sort of
looks like eastern Asia kind of coming
it's it's sort of it's very much and
then that those Lakes sort of have the
outline of North America just a little
bit it's kind of weird how we how we
sort of we get used to the way our
continents look and sort of then apply
that to different things i'm rambling
now
somebody quick ask a question before I
dig myself into a bigger hole
warp up here somebody asking about
high-tech future tech obviously we know
there's no faster than light travel is
there anything here that seems like it's
that that's currently out of reach based
on what we know they have ion drives
which those are on satellites currently
like flying around and they're like
improving that sort of technology and
then they have like nuclear engines but
if you like want to kind of go down that
road they have there's this mod called
interstellar actually it came up before
the movie and that's a really cool one
for like it just has all these like kind
of they're all supposed to be
theoretically possible or at least like
theorized to be but they get like into
warp-drive territory and you'll like
kind of unlock those slowly and they
have like really advanced more realistic
kind of nuclear simulations to so I mean
yeah it's just kind of like however you
want to play it there's probably
something there for you I really hope I
had no feel for this but yeah this is
definitely a game where you're gonna
have a lot of failures
the guy who's spending his day mocking
people in a chat room wants to know when
I'm going to get a life so I'll just let
that sit there he also mentions as an
awkward berry dr aqua Pierre dr pardon
me that's not too bad alright so the
idea then intersection is you're going
to try and get this number as close to
zero as possible these orange dots ok
alright hundred forty-six SAT there and
then like fine tune it later how much
shot like after touch control do you get
and when you're when you're actually
traveling you know what you know how
much control do you actually get over
like very direct control of I'm
controlling it with the like WASD keys
and then like yeah it's actually you get
pretty hands-on like once this game once
you're trying to dock it or something
like that I just need to get close to
this guy and then he can fly over I
don't need to dock with him but docking
is something that like you kind of
really need to get you're going to be
like tapping away at the keyboard pretty
quick it's like direct control there's
no autopilot in the game even if there
are like mods that can help you out with
that right there's some that somebody
asking me I mentioning thur Bolton
mentioning I haven't played this before
was I waiting for one point o release or
any thoughts on having it leave early
access since was one of the first games
to come out of that model it's I don't
think anything was really keeping me
away in in terms of it being early
access or not I think what was keeping
me away is just a matter of time at work
I end up spending so much time on really
long games and what
Ben's is that I I feel like in my free
time I try to I try to spend time with
things that are shorter and things that
are a little bit more shallow my worry
was something like this is in my free
time this is the only thing I'd be
playing I know me and I know that this
is the kind of thing where I would get
so stuck that I would just end up
playing this for hours and hours and
hours and hours and hours and my worry
about that is that for work I already
play things that take hours and hours
and hours and hours and hours and hours
like because I play so many RPGs yeah we
plan at work it's all so many hours well
we just received the witcher 3 today so
that'll be that'll be the hours and
hours and hours and hours but I mean
they give you an idea like i went from
blood-borne two pillars of eternity in a
row and so you know you go from like 160
our game to the next that in my free
time I end up playing things that take
two hours so yeah so it's definitely I
mean even to get like to learn the game
will take a long time and then you need
to be like okay now I know how to play
it what do I want to do so it's def it's
a time sink for sure yeah but on the
other hand sometimes I get into that
like but that's like I tend to shy away
from things like this or the sims or
MMOs in my like my Kevin time mm-hmm if
only because I do all that stuff for
work and then when Kevin time comes I
try to spread the love around I think
that if you were thinking about getting
into this game now is a pretty good time
cuz they like they changed the area
dynamics so like if I don't know if you
ask me like two weeks ago I'd say no
wait till it comes out because it's
gonna get everything's going to change
them so are we getting to the point
where I mean are there mods that take
you I mean obviously there are mods that
have different like a different solar
system but are there mods that try to
expand this into like an entire galaxies
worth of you know of space and try to
get you to move really far out beyond I
mean for example if I have a work drive
it does it seems like it's kind of
wasted if I'm not working to new solar
systems the warp horn I don't I feel
like there might be a mod
that I feel like I never used it i heard
it might be a little buggy but um yeah i
mean people are always making crazy
mamad so i don't know the warp drive one
is really cool to get really quick to
jewel which is their little Jupiter and
am I going to intersect this in all
right so this is all about like a lot of
time this game like if you're watching
it you won't realize but you spend a lot
of time staring at this nav ball down
here trying to make all the colors line
up and stuff right ok so I'm going yeah
i'll have to try and get this number
down
this
it's going up
and if I
should be kind of past this on
I do seem to have a fair bit of fuel but
then again you never know at the other
day I had to get out and push really
fast so i can try and slow down together
yeah so you can EV a and so I ran out of
feel completely so I had to like get out
and then get behind the rocket and just
actually push against it with my
character and then that brought it
really that brought it down just enough
that I could do a bunch of orbits and
slowly lose altitude with each one
you know I'm stressing I'm just like
closer I know you're not closer are
always like add the thing is i'll be
able to get to this guy but i don't know
if i'll have enough fuel to slow my
orbit down enough to get back so we're
potentially crashing again no we're
potentially getting lost in space oh ok
oh that sounds even better
I'm getting closer
if anyone actually has experience with
this game there knowing that I'm messing
this up a bit but not horribly oh
they're like with I don't know if this
is an actual mission it would be a
horrible message they're like really
careful with all the fuses again really
close though oh my god you're like just
200 metres away aah Josh it's so tiny
the pot is so tiny it's not just about
like how close I get to it's about
matching the exact orbit right so I
should be really close now we're in the
small numbers oh wow now you're actually
it looks like your your orbits a lot
more aligned at least yeah so now i
melted Vlad is in these visual range i
can actually see the pod up so one more
kind of turn around to go backwards this
is a lot easier with RCS but i don't
really have that very much of it okay so
i'll just try and get this number as
long as i can now and then try and do it
quick so i can switch over to it this is
it and then oh my god i think i already
rescued this guy
oh man you won't keep in there are empty
one how do you oh man well let's pretend
you picked them up all right ok here's
what we'll do we'll go over there and
grab all the snacks he lifts all right
all right whoa I didn't really know this
was part of it that's hysterical look at
that dude okay so now he's inside of it
so this actually reminds me a little bit
it's a rather different game but if
you're looking for something like this
but maybe on a smaller scale and with
you know maybe not quite so much of the
technical stuff outer wilds is was like
the igf winner I think and you can go
and download that and it uses a lot of
gravity based physics and gets you into
space do it and exploring it's not
really technical like this is but it
there's a little bit of the same feel so
worth checking out and this this is what
reminded me of it cuz you do a lot of
that get out of your ship on the planet
and go bounce around so you'll notice
the physics like if this was call of
duty or something that first level where
you could in ghosts where you were right
space totally you'd like slow to a stop
but that'll never happen here my orbital
be slightly different and then on the
other side all to eat like hundreds of
kilometers away but so this one it is
kind of tough to like stopping in a
relative sense alright so back there
snacks alright so let's see if we have
enough to get home well at least you've
retrieved the snacks it's really what
this games all about at the end of the
day I'm glad that we're we're spending
all of that money on space missions to
get the Doritos and space or whatever
your favorite snack is
now can he make it back ok so being
stranded in space I want to do this burn
where where the high step so wait till I
get over there all right warping ahead
all right and then go to normal speed
playing it retrograde
well write it on
deck has gone the wrong direction isn't
it yep good job Josh alright what have
you done why that's not good other
things upside down much fooled around
I'm stressed oh no oh maybe all right I
think you might be able to pull it off
I've got faith ok so I am only getting
to within a million miles of the planet
so this is a get out and push me so the
plan is I'm gonna do i need this thing
at all solar panels up there yeah
getting that yep not good so we're going
to get out get behind the tip for all
your aspiring astronaut it's to get out
and push this is the old NASA way and
out there and push I think I might be
too far off this is going to probably be
a lost in space mission if I was playing
this out at home this would be like okay
it's time to do a rescue mission all
right you just get back on he'd be
stranded you'd have to get somebody else
to come out and get them there's it's I
feel like it's always hard to find a
time to stop playing this game like you
always are like okay now i just thought
let me do this I can do this
can't see anything we're able to get a
enough of a push it didn't seem like
those his little backpacks thrusters
would be enough to really of course
without any friction you never know nope
it's yeah I don't think it'll happen I
do a rescue mission normally but um yeah
I mean that's kerbal space program
that's like the exact this is exactly
what would happen if I was blaming you
just can't kind of be afraid of that
happening the old advice is like if it
doesn't get far enough add more boosters
and if it falls apart atom or struts
that's like this game for you so this
would be going back to the drawing board
and adding more boosters cool but yeah I
think we did it well I'm entertained
come in in spite of the slow pace I I
really want to play this now I've
actually wanted to play it for some time
and we do have a review in in progress
so somebody out there I've got that's a
lovely sight to end on check that out um
but he's kind of adorable does he make
did they make noises there do they uh I
don't think so I just kind of curious it
seems like I can like hear what noise
they should make it kind of be like a
kind of thing ha so so i can use do that
for this this we can find it on the
bottom and loop it alright but yeah I
mean I've always tried to be I'm always
one here at the office being like kerbal
space program kerbal space for them I
want it to be game of the month next
month but it's gonna have to be up
against the witcher yeah that's that's
gonna be a tough month worse it's gonna
be me versus the world on that one but i
really i mean i'm excited for that game
but i just want everyone to try this one
out at least for a bit yeah Josh oh by
the way how much what's the price on
this one it just went up with one point
oh I think if it's not on sale it's like
forty dollars now oh that actually
sounds pretty reasonable for for a game
with this much stuff yeah and there's
tons of replayability with like the mod
scene and everything like that too so
yeah well Josh thanks for showing us
kerbal space program today now and 1.0
so official release whatever that means
in this age of the game especially
that's like early access like good for
them good for them yeah but thanks
everybody out there for joining us i'm
kevin van or josh shaw and i'm sure
we'll see you again on something real
soon so bye
you